some of these are not polynomials some
of them are polynomials let's talk about
it as we go through each example so this
first one f of X equals 2x to the fourth
minus 8 okay so what we want to take a
look at is that this is a difference of
two monomials monomial is just one term
okay and they're separated by plus or
minus those are the separate terms there
because this has two terms we call this
a binomial see two terms binomial like
bicycle two wheels then what we do is we
look at the term that has the highest
power and I'll see how this is a fourth
power so we can say that this is a
fourth degree or we could call it a
quartic so if we put all that together
this is called a quartic binomial okay
so let's just write that down for is
quartic for the degree quartic and
number of terms we'll say - or we could
say it's a binomial and then the leading
coefficient you when you write these
polynomials you want to write them in
descending order from the highest power
down to the lowest power and so the one
that leads it off that first one when
you write it in standard form is going
to be the leading coefficient that's -
and then the constant term is just the
number okay so that's just the negative
eight okay that's actually just degree
zero and and that's it so that's the
first one now the second one G of x
equals four X to the fifth you can see
this is just one group here one term so
this is called a monomial C one term
mono ok monomial so we're gonna write
monomial and then as far as the degree
you can see the highest power here is
five that's a fifth degree or you could
call it quintic so either one fifth
degree quintic either wants fine I'll
just write fifth degree okay
the leading coefficient is four and then
the constant term you can see really
there isn't a constant term or we could
say zero okay let's go to the next one
so H of x equals 2x minus seven
okay well this one you can see that it's
a binomial there's two terms okay so
let's just write that down binomial and
it looks like it's a first-degree see
how that's X to the first which means
that it's called first-degree or linear
like a line okay so I'll just write
linear for the degree and then the
leading coefficient is two and the
constant
is negative seven okay let's go to the
next one the next one f of X equals two
to the X plus four now this one is not
considered a polynomial when you look at
these polynomials we've worked with so
far notice that the variable is always
in the base you never have the variable
in the exponent position this is
actually called an exponential function
so this is not a polynomial so I'm just
going to write we're just going to cross
right through that one okay not not
applicable the next one here you can see
we've got X to the negative two plus
three X okay this one is also not a
polynomial you you don't want to have a
negative exponent okay that's considered
not a polynomial you want these
exponents to be integers you want them
to be positive and that so this one
doesn't fall into that category this is
actually like one divided by x squared
plus 3x so again this is not a
polynomial let's look at this one now
this one same thing we've got the
variable in the denominator notice these
other polynomials we never had the
variable in denominator one over X is
the same as X to the negative one we
don't want that negative exponent that's
not considered a polynomial so again
this one is not a polynomial and then
let's take a look at these last two
examples but before I do these I just
want to mention that if you're preparing
for the AC T or the SAT check out my two
video courses the huge AC t-- math
review video course and the huge SAT
math review video course goes through a
number of different concepts to help you
boost your score on those particular
tests if you're getting ready to take
those check those out but let's go to
these last two examples X 2 the square
root 2 plus 3 again not a polynomial
because you have a non integer exponent
so this is not a polynomial and then the
last one here we've got 4 x squared
minus 2x plus 1 this one you can see
it's a second-degree that's the highest
power second-degree we call a quadratic
okay and you can see that it's 1 2 3
terms 3 groups we call that a trinomial
like a tricycle right 3 wheels so we've
got 1 2 3 so this is a degree to which
is a quadratic sometimes students get
quadratic and kortek confused quark tic
is actually 4 and quadratic is actually
a second degree and then this is a
trinomial and leading coefficient is 4
that's the one that leads it off
and the constant term is positive one
and I'm just going to give you one more
bonus one here and notice that all these
ones here they all have just one
variable just like X so say for example
we were to do something like this 5x
squared Y cubed minus 3 X Y squared well
here what you want to do see these terms
are separated by you know minus or plus
you want to add up those exponents so
this is 2 plus 3 is 5 ok this one is 1
plus 2 which is actually 3 so the
highest power is 5 this would actually
be a fifth-degree binomial okay so if
you have more than one variable add up
those exponents for that particular term
that's a little bit more of an advanced
one usually when they're doing these
problems with you in your class or
you're taking a look at these you only
have one variable generally but
sometimes they do give you two or three
or four variables so I hope this helped
you understand how to classify
polynomials better check out more math
tutoring videos on my youtube channel
Mario's math tutoring and I look forward
to helping you in the future of math
videos and if you have any other
questions or things that you want me to
maybe do future videos on feel free to
let me know send me an email and you
could potentially be featured in one of
the future videos so I'll talk to you
soon